in what kind of situations does the
Poisson process arise in general it
arises whenever we have events like
arrivals that are somewhat rare and
which happen in a completely
uncoordinated manner so that they can
show up at any particular time in such
situations the number of arrivals will
be often described by a certain
distribution called the Poisson
distribution
and which is named after the person who
first studied this situation who is a
famous French mathematician by the name
of siméon Denis Poisson an early example
where the data seems to fit the
description of the Poisson process is a
curious one it had to do with deaths
from horse kicks that is accidental
deaths in the Prussian army the idea
here is that the death by horse kick can
happen pretty much at any time and
different arrivals that these different
accidents are completely uncoordinated
from each other so the process is sort
of completely random for more scientific
applications it was realized that
certain physical phenomena obey the
Poisson process
examples are the following you have some
radioactive body which decays and the
decay happens by once in a while
emitting various particles different
particles get emitted at completely
random times in a completely
uncoordinated manner and therefore this
process is actually described as a
Poisson process conversely if you have a
photo detector who looks at a very weak
light source so photons arrive from that
weak light source one at a time and you
look at the times at which photons hit
the photo detector then the process of
photon arrivals is very well modeled by
a Poisson process for more modern
applications if you look at the
financial markets and the times at which
certain very unexpected events like
certain market shocks occur a model that
is commonly employed is to use a Poisson
process
although this is not an entirely
accurate model it provides first
approach to situations like this but
these days the predominant source of
applications from the Poisson process is
in various service operations you are
the phone company phone calls get placed
at random times and because there are
several people involved who are
uncoordinated with each other and those
calls get placed at completely random
times and the same story goes about
let's say service requests to a web
server service request to any kind of
company so many applications that are
being studied these days and which rest
on Poisson models involve service
operations of this type